in the meantime I turn to my phone line
I'm fine from NBC sports Boston mom my
friend Tom Caron how are you Tom
I am tremendous rich how are you today I
am doing great thank you how to reach
out to you to see what your thoughts are
first of all let's go here if I if I
cobbled together the amount of time
you've had one-on-one interviewing Tom
Brady how far back would I have to go to
cobble together two hours and nine
minutes the amount of time the amount of
time that Howard Stern got from Tom
today that's that's a really good
question um string it together one on
top of the other what do you think
probably probably oh oh six and nine
consecutive minutes Brady gave to Howard
Stern today because that's the thing is
it and you know it as well you're
dealing with people who have a lot of
people pulling on their threats and the
last thing you want to do is when that
person sees you coming have them start
to say uh that comes this guy with his
15 minutes of monopolizing my time so
when I add something for him it was hit
quick get the flip out oh that is hey
what's up buddy hey what's up so no way
I was getting close to two hours over
the over a period of time he and I hung
out Believe It or Not in 2005 at a bar
in Boston unexpectedly for about an hour
hour and fifteen so that would probably
be the the longest tenured continuous
babble we had was that back in his days
where he could slam beers type days he
wasn't due he was straight straight on
the water it I think was his sister
Nancy was a bartender at the place was
called the news and he and a couple of
friends of couple other Patriots where
there was a after Monday Night Football
game and I had gone there with my
brother after a Celtics game in December
and he had said that he'd be there he
was there so we just hung around just
normal flippin guy he is he is that I
mean the guy really is when you when it
comes down to it and I mean kind of got
a glimpse of that today
don't you think yeah and that's the
funny thing is you know so many people
talk about him as you know Robo human
and you know
per quarterback he's not she's just a
nice guy so you're not gonna get the
poopster and and the passive
aggressiveness that you won't get with
many other people you and me included I
mean over the course of time he probably
more than you but he's just such a nice
guy that he's living on the high road
you and I both know and I think that
most of our listeners if they look at it
objectively know that well there were
access to grind on both sides tom is not
psyched about the way things went
certainly over 20 years with his
relationship with Bill Belichick they
came to a mutual understanding he's not
changing for me Brady would think and
bill certainly was gonna and Tom it a
point was like I'm 42 I'm not changing
for him but he keeps living on the high
road and I think that was the
interesting thing about this
conversation today which we had all the
insight we fed it to people all the last
two or three years about where the
relationship was but Brady really put a
buff and shine on where things were I
thought today and and made it this is
what it was but it wasn't as
confrontational it's folks like to make
it seem agree or disagree you know what
III didn't hear all 209 minutes of it to
be honest with you and that's part of
the reason why I'm having you on here
and you know I would agree however
because I'm always and this is the way I
broadcast this is the way I talk this is
the way I go about my business tom is
that everything is always more nuanced
then than the black and white
conversation that sports talk normally I
guess defaults to in in our business and
that's why I was pleased to hear a lot
of this stuff but that's why I also
wanted to have you on here too to add
the the background and the nuance to it
so let's get to it Tom the first order
of business that he said he when Howard
Stern asked him when he knew it was done
with New England and the point that he
mentioned as most likely for it was
prior to the season and I know you've
been talking about that quite a bit so I
give you the floor on what you thought
of that
confirmation just of where things were
and you heard it on the first day of
trading camp his irritation with not
having a deal at that point that it was
confirming for him that they don't want
me around through my 43 year old season
as I've told them as they've told me
that they would do they're not going to
do it they were going to give me the
drew brees deal for two and fifty and
they're not doing it not going to
guarantee that second year and that's
when he kind of lobbed it across and
said ask mr. Kraft jokingly and that was
when he was turning it look I'm done
playing nice here I'm done beating
around the bush you tell me why I'm not
getting an extension so I thought that
was concrete and also I think that you
know what was going on behind the scenes
was more rancor that there was a
discussion that had to take place and an
extension that had to be given and a
race that had to be given before the
Patriots were sure that Tom Brady was
going to participate throughout the
preseason and and not walk away from
football quite honestly and they took
care of that posthaste when I think it
started to dawn on people how pissed he
was so he was playing last did you get a
sense during last season that this was a
guy and and at what points did did you
did you have it in your in your idea
confirmed that this was a guy he's
playing you threw out his last season in
New England in Tennessee when the
Patriots went down there for their
training camp meetings with Tennessee
and he basically was saying look we're
just you know I'm just an employee here
they don't ask me questions they don't
ask me well purchased personnel I'm not
here to coach he was really divesting
himself I thought of the
responsibilities that he wanted to have
as a culture cultivator as a an on-field
coach because the team had started to
marginalize him so that's when I was oh
boy yeah this is he is embracing me you
don't want me around well I'll just be
another cog in the machine I'm employing
number twelve over here working out of
my locker that was when I started to see
it and you saw it rich time week in and
week out his inability to to polish the
turd that
the office his post came he just wasn't
going to do it by the way that was my
favorite album and I think it was during
the high school years polish that turd
yeah they were great they were they were
terrific they were a great band we
remember some of their great songs yeah
right never mind right could come up
with a couple there there there I guess
revival tour polished the turd in 2019
the the big hit was New England's
receiving corps clearly so yeah we're
still sitting here he did here that's
running the wrong route you know so
Brady kind of touched on that today
didn't he with Howard yes and I thought
that was telling too and was interesting
to hear him say that bill would you know
be on the same page with them but you
know this wasn't related you know so
many people on the timelines up here I'm
watching the timelines of folks I'm on
the beat with and and the fans who are
you know very involved and very
up-to-date on things like does Harry
know it's it's Joey Galloway it's you
know you name it over the course of time
it's Chad Jackson it's Vicky Larry now
but it's always that it's Ben Watson
when Ben Watson started even it's like
what the hell is Ben wants to do and he
just it's it's all of those guys he was
not going to accept close enough and he
worked for a coach who made that mindset
possible for him close enough ain't
gonna cut it
I'm not throwing it to the guy bill yeah
yeah you're right you know I will go get
will get rachet call blows your bio gas
D they know where to go we might not be
that great but at least they know what
it's supposed to be and that's what they
would do and so you think that's why he
chose the Bucs because there's God when
there's Evans I mean at least he knows
that that's that's that's well we
honestly I think there was a woman more
than the players who he can say well
maybe I could work with and maybe I'm
gonna have to look at some roots that I
want to run at 14 that I run at 17 but
at least I know they want me there
at least I know that it's two years it's
at least the commitment that they want
me there so if I yell at these guys I
can yell at him without the coaches
looking at me and going you're a
short-timer man you're only here for
this year let's we'll do the coaching of
Nikhil Harry cuz you're gonna be here
for one eighth of his career pal
so we'll take care of that that's not
going to happen in Tampa they will say
it's ok for you to yell at these guys
and teach them how to do their jobs
really that's that's the essence of it
Tom realized he was a short-timer in New
England Wow
and that they took some of this ability
to coach yell at instruct away and he
was in there and you know in the
Patriots defense he wasn't there the
OTAs in minicamp loads differently camp
but he wasn't there for a lot of the
stuff where stuff would put in so they
needed to know who to look to and they
needed to look to Josh they needed to
look to Joe judge who was just five
receivers coach and not the Tom Brady
who might only be there for the next
four months which is what happened so um
let me put in a hit pin in the OTA stuff
in a second cuz he did hit on that and
explained why he wasn't at OTAs and it
was a family
I guess decision or issue however you
want to put it so are you telling me
that the sixth time Super Bowl winner
the guy who took him to let's get this
right nine correct yes in 20 years that
guy was viewed as a short-timer because
everybody knew what time it was that
Brady mentioned in the Howard Stern
interview today that he pinpointed last
summer is the time where he realized he
wasn't coming back and it was told don't
get on these kids don't coach him up
don't be Tom Brady red ass with these
guys because we'll handle that is that
what you were telling me Tom really yeah
it was it was made pretty clear to him
that they really didn't need the
negativity now what he told don't yell
at anyone ever if he was he didn't do a
good job of that but I remember clearly
during that Tennessee training camp
joint session that they had there was a
play and I think I think it was Jacoby
Myers might have been gunner one of
these
the guys could have been whoever the kid
was landed up with jets Braxton Barrios
he was lined up on the wrong side and
Brady Moyes we watching a game will tell
that guy to get to the other side
instead it was really telling he looked
at Josh and pointed at the player and
then Brady just stood there with his
hands on his hips and Josh went over
told the kid to get to the other side
and the kid went to the other side and
then the play commenced and again I
don't blame the Patriots for doing that
in some ways as coaches but that is you
sat there in one of the most telling
aspects I thought of Tom Brady's
relationship with Bill Belichick you sat
at that same table rich and watch Brady
talk about the relationship that he had
with Bill and that Manning had with his
teams and somewhat enviously it seemed
at times you know the the control that
Payton had that Brady didn't and at 42
it was even less so what do you make Tom
of Brady saying the reason why I wasn't
at OTAs a couple years ago and I'm
imagining this year as well is he
he needed to do more at home that his
wife was essentially saying hey you know
the seasons long enough that you're now
spring with all the kids growing up it's
time for you to take the school pick him
up etc be a be more present at home what
would you make of that comment Tom I
believe that that conversation certainly
could have taken place as it as it does
in many many many people's homes
when this needs to be a division of
parental duties and the like dawns on
Marblehead you like having I I need to
do more if you're not I find it hard to
fathom that he couldn't slice off two
hours of time during the days to get
down to Gillette for workouts
a few times a week I think there was
more to it than that specifically I
think what there was to it was that look
if you're gonna pay me fifteen million
dollars and not give me the extension
I'm looking for
I am sure it's crap not showing up for
this voluntary stuff where I'm not
getting paid at all into extra field so
but I think the two things can both be
true right huh
you're paying me 31 honey look I get
what you're saying but they just made
this commitment to me that I never
thought they would make I got to go to
most of these at least some of them I
think the both can be true Tom Curren
here on the Rich Eisen show what else
from the interview am I not asking you
about that that you think was
significant or shed light on something
that we need to know the the was it the
the I wouldn't have been successful as
successful without Belichick and I feel
the vice versa I mean what what is that
one yeah me the main one that sticks out
to me and it's something I wrote about
December I said look this could be an
amicable divorce and I wrote at the time
do they even really need to sit down at
the table and negotiate because this
isn't about money or anything this is
about Eric two sizable differences Tom
believes he could play at a certain
level till he's 43 and deserves to be
paid at a certain level 43 44 45 bill
doesn't believe that and Tom to say look
that's that's how bill felt and that was
his right and that's what he's supposed
to do and I was in a stage where I was
doing things that he didn't expect to
see I think that was the most honest
part and that's why we're even on the
phone right now in April talking about
Tom Brady Tampa Bay Buccaneer is because
of those chemical excusing those
irreconcilable differences but I think
that they're trying that least tom is
really hard to make it an amicable split
while still going up what bill would say
look why are we doing any interviews who
are you gonna take another why would why
would continue to talk about this it's
probably bothering him but Torme remains
on the high road I think if he goes
through this but that's the fact of it
Brady wanted to play for the Patriots
longer the Patriots didn't want to pay
him to keep playing for them when they
weren't sure he was going to keep
playing at the same level that's what
was true after 2017 it was true after
2018 and it was true this offseason they
didn't want to commit
so Tom Curren the question is who's next
in that spot we are let me do this right
I fifteen days away from the NFL Draft
going down right I mean I think we're
that's a that's an accurate number yeah
it's two weeks from Thursday NFL Draft
going down right now
the quarterback room is Jared Stidham
and Brian Hoyer is that their
quarterback room and who gets added to
it what do you got for me
Stidham and Hawaii are gonna be the main
stage we'll see if anyone's added to the
draft my feeling is if there is somebody
added to the draft it will probably be a
top 12 type player that hasn't happened
to fall I don't know if the Patriots are
in a position to give away draft
resources because they haven't dressed
well the last five seasons so if they're
starting to give away first-round picks
to get up and draft somebody in
second-round third-round picks
I think that's cuckoo they need to
replenish and get younger so I really
think it'll be Brady
excuse me rice and and Hoyer are gonna
be in there and the opportunity will be
there for him but what's huge is you
look back at guys who were quarterbacks
in 2010 as rookies going into the 2011
season Colt McCoy gave voice to this
it was incredibly damaging to him as a
quarterback going into his second year
to lose that offseason because of the
lockout and this is gonna be damaging to
these guys developments to guys like
Stidham because they're gonna lose a lot
of this so it's good that they have were
here but watch this whole group of 2010
quarterbacks and see how many excuse me
in 2019 quarterbacks and see how many
are compromised a little bit in their
development well I mean let's talk brass
tacks then Tom Curran because you know
then it Bella checks brilliant he knows
that I'm sure he knows exactly what you
just said about Colt McCoy and he knows
that
sidam is missing some valuable time and
he might cover obviously stim and his
abilities and that's why they brought
Brian Hoyer and but Hoyer last year in
that system in Indianapolis we're clear
Brissette was thriving before he got
hurt and we all talked about how Frank
Reich is a quarterback guru or he looked
terrible there's no other way to put it
that the Colts could not score their
entire season got kneecapped when the
knee of Presets gave way so what about a
free agent what about somebody else
being brought in now we know there's
Jameis outstare out there we also know
what Scott Pioli said how cam wouldn't
be a fit for Belichick charlie weis told
us when he came on that he thought
dalton would be the best fit for the
system is any of that do you think
possible post draft if the draft does
not go the way for the Patriots to add a
third here I was just told during the
whole process before Brady left that
they didn't believe that their team
would be and veteran quarterback
mid-tier did the market for that kind of
player so that could certainly change if
they don't get someone in the draft to
add in that quarterback room but you
don't have a lot of cap room and if
you're gonna even if Andy Dalton wants
more than 7 million which is what
Mariota is getting I believe in Oakland
to compete
what's all-time gonna settle for which
game is going to settle for are you
gonna give these guys multi-year deals
I just they're screwed I mean they're up
against it against the cap their roster
is kind of old they've done poorly in
the last five drafts they got big
problems that fortunately they have the
best coach to ever do it who can make
sure that this isn't a three four or
five win team but they have big problems
to address that just bringing in Andy
Dalton who may slow the progress of a
Stidham or whoever else you draft I
don't think it's a great idea yeah I
mean we had Jalen Hertz on I asked him
if any of his zoom interviews involved
somebody who knew Nick Saban very very
well and he laughed and said no comment
so you know I know I know they don't
have a - because that's in Atlanta's
possession because of the Mohamed Sanu
trade so what do you think about that is
a possibility
yeah I mean trade back 100% 100% trade
back from the 23rd overall pick and get
that second round pick and add another
pick terrific that's go ahead ask the
question you just asked me Chris before
we let Tom go yeah Tom there's been some
rumors about Julian Edelman involved in
trade talks what do you think I was told
no chance in hell and I believe that
germinated first was an April Fool's
prank that was jumped on by our friend
Bill Simon and and he asked Colin
Cowherd about it and it passed on down
the line and you know with everything
rumored about the Patriots they do so
many stunning moves that you have to go
well I mean that's what I'm hearing but
apparently it emanated first was an
April Fool's prank that it was happening
that it gained some traction from you
know from what I was told
quote not a chance in hell alright well
Tom look for our call next week you'll
be hearing from us that's for darn sure
we'll have you back on all right guys
thanks a lot thank you you got stung
turn hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here